El sol resplandece.
Los pájaros cantan.
Parece el comienzo de otro día encantador.
Estás paseando felizmente
por el parque cuando... "¡Achís!".
Un extraño que pasaba te ha rociado
con moco y saliva de su boca y nariz.
Puedes sentir cómo las gotas
de humedad aterrizan sobre tu piel,
pero lo que no puedes sentir
son los miles, incluso millones
de gérmenes microscópicos que
han viajado inadvertidamente por el aire
hasta tu ropa, manos y rostro.
Tan asquerosa
como suena la descripción,
es de hecho muy común
que nuestros organismo
se exponga a gérmenes
causantes de enfermedades,
y la mayoría de las veces,
no es ni tan obvio.
Los gérmenes están
en casi todas las superficies
con las que entramos en contacto.
Cuando hablamos de gérmenes,
nos referimos a muchos tipos
de organismos microscópicos,
incluyendo las bacterias, los hongos,
los protozoos y los virus.
Pero lo que nuestros gérmenes
tienen en común es la habilidad
de interactuar con nuestros cuerpos
y cambiar cómo nos sentimos
y funcionamos.
Los científicos que estudian
las enfermedades infecciosas
se han preguntado por décadas
por qué algunos de estos gérmenes
son relativamente inofensivos,
mientras otros tienen
efectos devastadores,
y son a veces fatales.
Aún no hemos resuelto todo el acertijo
pero lo que sabemos es que
la gravedad o la virulencia de un germen
es el resultado de la evolución.
¿Cómo es posible que el mismo
proceso evolutivo
pueda producir gérmenes que causan
distintos niveles de daño?
La respuesta es clara si pensamos
sobre el modo de transmisión
de los gérmenes,
que es la estrategia que usan
para pasar de un huésped a otro.
Un modo común de transmisión
ocurre a través del aire,
como el estornudo que viste,
y un germen que usa este método
es el rinovirus,
que se multiplica en nuestros
pasajes respiratorios
y es responsable de hasta la mitad
de los resfriados comunes.
Ahora imagina que luego del estornudo,
una de las tres variedades hipotéticas
de rinovirus,
llamémoslas "demasiado",
"muy poco" y "lo justo",
tuvo la suerte de llegar a ti.
Estos virus están diseñados
para multiplicarse
pero debido a las diferencias genéticas
lo harán a velocidades diferentes.
"Demasiado" se multiplica con frecuencia,
lo que lo hace exitoso a corto plazo.
Sin embargo, su éxito viene
con un costo para ti, el huésped.
Un virus que se multiplica rápidamente
puede causar más daño a tu cuerpo,
haciendo que los síntomas
del resfriado sean más severos.
Si estás demasiado enfermo
para salir de casa,
no darás al virus la oportunidad
de lograr un nuevo huésped.
Y si la enfermedad te mata,
el ciclo de vida del virus
se terminará contigo.
"Muy poco", por otra parte,
raramente se multiplica
y te causa muy poco daño en el proceso.
Esto te deja lo suficientemente saludable
para que interactúes
con otros huéspedes potenciales,
pero la falta de síntomas significa
que quizás no estornudes,
y si lo haces, quizás haya muy pocos virus
en tus mocos para infectar a otros.
Mientras tanto, "lo justo"
se ha multiplicado
lo suficientemente rápido
para asegurarse que llevarás
suficiente cantidad de virus
para contagiar,
pero no tantos como para que estés
demasiado enfermo
y te quedes en cama.
Al final es el más exitoso
en transmitirse a nuevos huéspedes
creando una nueva generación.
Esto describe lo que los científicos
llaman la hipótesis de intercambio.
Se desarrolló primero
en los inicios de los 80,
y predice que los gérmenes evolucionarán
para maximizar su éxito
al lograr un equilibrio entre
su multiplicación dentro de un huésped,
que causa la virulencia,
y la transmisión a un nuevo huésped.
En el caso del rinovirus
la hipótesis predice que su evolución
favorecerá formas menos virulentas
porque depende del contacto cercano
para llegar a la próxima víctima.
Para el rinovirus, un huésped móvil
es un buen huésped,
y, de hecho, eso es lo que vemos.
Mientras la mayoría
moquea, tose y estornuda,
el resfriado común es por lo general
leve y solo dura una semana.
Sería maravilloso
si la historia terminara aquí,
pero los gérmenes utilizan
muchas formas de transmisión.
Por ejemplo, el parásito de la malaria,
el plasmodio,
lo transmiten mosquitos.
A diferencia del rinovirus,
no nos necesita para funcionar,
e incluso se beneficiaría
al hacernos daño
porque es más fácil para un mosquito
picar a una persona enferma e inmóvil.
Suponemos que los gérmenes
que dependen menos
de la movilidad del huésped,
como los que se transmiten a través
de mosquitos, agua o alimentos,
causan síntomas más severos.
Entonces, ¿qué podemos hacer para reducir
la gravedad de una enfermedad infecciosa?
El Dr. Paul Ewald, biólogo evolutivo,
sugiere que podemos dirigir
su evolución con simples métodos
de control de enfermedades.
Con casas a prueba de mosquitos,
aguas limpias,
o quedarnos en casa
cuando estamos resfriados,
podemos bloquear las estrategias
de transmisión de los gérmenes dañinos,
al crear una gran dependencia
en la movilidad del huésped.
Mientras los métodos tradicionales
para erradicar gérmenes
solo puede crear unos más fuertes
a largo plazo,
este método innovador
de motivarlos
para que evolucionen
a formas menos dañinas
puede ser una situación
en la que todos ganan.
(Tos)
Bueno, en casi la mayoría de las veces.